[Music]
senator bernie sanders wants the federal
government to provide a $15 per hour job
to every american who wants one it's
hard to overstate how silly this
proposal is taxes could never be raised
and existing programs could never be cut
enough to finance this policy at the
level required and the government could
not possibly come up with enough jobs to
satisfy its obligations under this plan
this cartoonish proposal is predicated
in part on the notion that there are bad
jobs jobs that are beneath the dignity
of what a reasonable person should
expect for employment it's true of
course that many jobs are physically
demanding and pay relatively little but
it's also true that work confers dignity
and is virtuous flipping burgers for $10
an hour isn't a bad job it's an
opportunity to build skills and climb
the employment ladder it's an
opportunity to provide for yourself and
your family it's an opportunity to make
a contribution to your community and to
society all leaders should encourage
work leaders shouldn't denigrate even
unintentionally the jobs held by
millions of hardworking Americans that
message is counterproductive messages
matter what do you think about said
under Sanders proposal for a guaranteed
job for every American let us know in
your comments also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI